American Girl dolls accidentally became
memes and this is that story I'm Barrett
I'm Carter and this is Felicity so my
best friend Carter and I run the account
Felicity Merriman together we met about
five years ago
we had the same job at the time and one
of the very first things that we bonded
over was both having American Girl dolls
growing up so we were spending a lot of
time getting to know each other and our
other co-workers largely through a
series of personality quizzes that we
would find online one of those was the
BuzzFeed which American Girl doll are
you quiz which she and I instantly
bonded over because we have both grown
up with those dolls and had read those
books and were really familiar with the
characters we not only took the quiz
ourselves but it became a bit of like a
team building exercise for basically our
our entire staff we all knew who
everyone's American Girl doll was it was
a bit like being sorted into your Harry
Potter house we knew who was a Ravenclaw
and we also knew who was Josefina we
actually once went on a business lunch
together to the American Girl doll cafe
it became kind of an in joke throughout
out the course of our friendship then in
late 2021 we were living separately in
different cities and bonded because we
began seeing American Girl doll memes
from other creators on Twitter mostly
and we would send them back and forth to
each other and laugh together and I
think it was just very organic in terms
of coming up with our own ideas for
things that would be funny featuring
American Girl dolls in February of this
year after a few glasses of wine I just
kind of decided to take these ideas that
we were coming up with and actually make
an account Carter texted me one day and
said I made us our own American Girl me
and Macau the name is helicity Merriman
and here's the login details I want us
to do this together the first memes we
ever made for the account were super
stream of Consciousness whatever we
thought would be funny to see an
American Girl doll doing a lot of the
original ones were like fake YouTube
thumbnails
um with like real YouTube titles we had
absolutely no intention of this ever
taking off in the way it has but we were
dead wrong
and then we started to make the we need
an American Girl doll Who memes that
really blew up we were not the first
account that actually posted we need an
American Girl doll who XYZ but it was
sort of a mean format that we had seen
once or twice one day I just had like a
bunch of ideas posted them on the
account and very quickly the comments
started rolling in people started
sharing those on Tick Tock and in their
stories all over the place and it really
exploded from there Carter and I both
have a background working in politics
and we're both very involved in politics
so that was inevitably going to be a big
part of what we wanted to communicate
through these memes a lot of our
followers will note that one of the
first big memes that brought them to the
account was our reaction to Roe versus
Wade being overturned back in June of 20
22 and there's actually a funny story
that goes along with that at the time I
was actually on a mountain with no cell
service and you know had kind of told
Barrett do whatever you want with the
account while I'm offline she posted a
meme about just news because we had
commented on it in the past and the
lead-up to this announcement that our
followers would be looking to us to say
something else now that it had been made
official I mocked up something really
quickly shot it over to her and said
this is what I have I'm gonna post it if
you can't respond to me but I really
want your feedback later that day was
driving down the mountain and started
getting pings on my phone very
serendipitously she was just coming down
off the mountain and she texted me and
she was like oh my God this is wild but
I love it go ahead and post it it's one
of those moments that I will always kind
of remember like what I was doing where
was I when the Taylor Swift look what
you made me do music video dropped what
was I doing when we found out this news
that roway was getting overturned I was
driving down the mountain and I found
out about it from a meme on my own meme
page and realizing that this meme about
this decision was blowing up
that got us like 40 000 followers in the
span of one day over a million people
saw the post it started getting printed
out and taken to protests we saw photos
of that sign at protests in the New York
Times it was all very bizarre it's
surreal we haven't had any direct
contact with the American Girl doll
brand that being said a lot of their
employees have actually reached out to
us obviously our content maybe not the
most child friendly in the world but
they're very much aware of the account
and they love it a lot since we started
this account in 2022 midterm election
year and because some of the political
content we were making did so well
Carter and I felt like it made sense for
us to use this account to do something
that we care about a lot which is
getting young people to the polls
talking about it in a way that feels
like we're talking to our peers and
we're not reading off some stuffy
messaging that I think really just
doesn't work
one of my favorite things about the
account is that it really has felt like
a growing Community people send us a ton
of things tons of stories lots of
pictures honestly at this point we would
have expected everybody to have
unfollowed the account but we're still
growing a little bit every day
foreign
[Music]